is cocaine a nice
even if you have a hangover would you
say it
well it's more of if i'm really drunk
thing
you know cocaine's weird now because
the day of doing it with strangers in a
bathroom is over because you might have
fun you just can't trust the drugs
anymore we're having to run around with
drug testing kids like [ __ ] a police
officer you know what i'm saying we're
like testing [ __ ] with testing strips
yeah because you might die yeah it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] up dude guy what is so
cool when you could just bump into a
stone cold stranger at a bar and he's
like wanna hit a bumper like [ __ ] yeah
he was like the mountain fairy he would
just be in there pulling little
mountains of coke on the end of a key or
a [ __ ] car you didn't know this dude
you were just like thank you mountain
fairy i'll take another little hill and
you're just hitting them with them and
y'all are [ __ ] partying in the
bathroom you don't [ __ ] know each
other and then you leave you're like i
just did some killer blow with that dude
in the bathroom but dude's [ __ ] off
he was raking him out son and now your
dude's in the bathroom like you want to
hit some blow and i'm like i want to see
you do a whole eight ball first first
show me you can do it yeah and how long
have you been doing this blow you might
have already got accustomed to the
amount of fentanyl in it and that might
not be you know a lot of people that are
dealing with that [ __ ] like the overdose
[ __ ] because i know it's happening a lot
like everywhere man we had a really bad
few years in nashville especially with
old friends from the neighborhood that
kind of went from pills to shooting [ __ ]
and just you know
that whole culture is just out here
they're like uh
i watch way too much random [ __ ] on
youtube but there's this guy named dark
white underbelly you watch your [ __ ]
so he interviews like prostitutes and
like murderers and all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] but
dude
in la like in [ __ ] uh where's the
homeless people that skid row yeah
they're all like they don't want i was
just gonna say where are they not no no
they don't want um normal drugs like
they're they specifically are smoking
fentanyl like they're like
proof they're like fentanyl proof these
[ __ ] crackheads but i think it's like
everything else like once your body has
felt it and gets it
in certain amounts you can but i think
it's just i don't get it at all i don't
understand so it's definitely put a
damper on my cocaine i've heard i'm in
the prime of my career i should be out
here living like [ __ ] jerry buss in
the 70s [ __ ] 80s i should be out here
just fine
me and my wife should just be out here
[ __ ] [ __ ] and [ __ ] doing just
[ __ ] just
piles of cocaine every night and
drinking scotch for breakfast
and instead we're having to run around
like
she's probably got a std and that
cocaine's probably got phenol in it
jesus yep just wrong wrong area that
makes me think about this have you ever
thought about what the backstage looked
like at a concert in the 70s and 80s oh
oh yeah i mean i bet it was amazing dude
there was not a camera in sight yeah i
just imagine topless women running
around and passing out heroin kids
heroin kids uh [ __ ] dick pills
shout out right
yo here's a blue chew
and a [ __ ] shot of heroin right and
they're just running around and
everybody's just origin by the way go to
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg and get
your first month free there you go baby
go to the bluetooth.com and look at see
i'll run your promos for you gotta have
read i'll do it with you right now the
blue chews work they do work i know
shoals
souls convinced me too have you tried
one yeah i took a blue shoe you wake up
in the morning that dick hard the wind
blows and it's like hello you have that
piss boner you gotta get out in the
morning yeah and i i just i need all the
help i can get in that department hey
man
as belly goes out it goes in it's like a
turtle just receding it's just getting
the [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] bad dude it's disappearing
and smelling bad i'm not looking for
sure
[Music]
it's [ __ ] horrible
maybe that's why we're not having orgies
backstage doing cocaine too the turtle
don't come out much when he does he
smells like a swamp
[Laughter]
i can't believe my wife loves me i'm
[ __ ] such a disappointment
[Laughter]